Наймасштабніші протести у Польщі за останні кілька десятиліть.
На вулиці виходять не лише жінки, а загалом - молодь. Вони протестують проти драконівських законів щодо абортів.
Аборти у Польщі будуть заборонені, навіть якщо ембріон з вадами розвитку і новонароджений,
імовірно, помре одразу після пологів. Жінок зачепило те, як нахабно держава відбирає в них їхні права.
Я жінка, я мати, я маю доньку і вважаю, що я тут не тільки заради себе,
але й заради моєї доньки, аби її майбутнє було кращим.
І я вважаю, що це важливо для всіх, хто живе у Польщі. Ось чому я тут.
Я ніколи не брала участі у вуличних протестах. Але відчула, що мушу.
Ніколи так сильно не відчувала, що хтось просто сміється мені в обличчя!
Я з католицької родини. І мушу боротися з тим, що думають про все це мої батьки.
Але я намагаюся говорити з ними, тому що в мене таке відчуття,
немовби наше суспільство багато років вражене жахливою хворобою.
Марта Лемпарт з руху "Жіночий страйк", яка координує протести, каже, що жінки більше не хочуть бути "милими".
Тепер, пояснює активістка, вони вже навіть не цураються нецензурної лайки.
Вульгарними словами жінки підкріплюють свої вимоги - це відставка уряду та обмеження влади церкви.
Ми хочемо мати світську державу, яка не фінансує церкву і де релігія не викладається у школах.
Але перш за все нам потрібна відставка уряду.
Війна з правими консерваторами в нас триває вже 5 років.
Підвищився лише її градус.
Але й польська влада додала градусу ескалації.
Віцепрем'єр та лідер партії "Право і справедливість" Ярослав Качинський назвав опозицію та протестувальників "злочинцями".
Ви наражаєте на смертельну небезпеку багатьох людей. Ви злочинці, просто злочинці!
Качинський закликав прибічників обороняти церкву та храми.
Я ще раз повторюю: ми мусимо протидіяти цьому.
Це обов'язок держави, але також усіх нас, обов'язок усіх громадян.
Ми маємо захистити польські церкви. Будь-якою ціною.
Ми дійшли до стадії терору. Спочатку погрожував прем'єр Моравецький, тепер Качинський.
Думаю, це ті, хто сам боїться. Люди це знають і будуть продовжувати протести.
Поштовхом для протестів у Польщі стало рішення Конституційного суду.
Він розцінив аборти, навіть у разі виявлення у плоду дефекту чи важкого захворювання,
як порушення гарантованого у Польщі права на життя.
І звузив право на аборт до мінімуму -  лише у разі загрози здоров'ю вагітної
або якщо вагітність стала наслідком зґвалтування або інцесту.
У Польщі вже і так одні з найсуворіших законів про аборти.
І офіційно робиться лише близько тисячі абортів на рік, виключно за діагностування важкої аномалії ембріона.
Та водночас, за оцінками громадських організації, в країні проводиться 100 тисяч нелегальних абортів.
І у 98 відсотках цих випадків причина - аномалії в розвитку плоду.
Протестувальники вважають Конституційний суд "кишеньковим".
Багато експертів ставлять під сумнів і юридичну коректність вердикту.
Влада відклала публікацію скандального рішення.
Президент Анджей Дуда, аби заспокоїти ситуацію, запропонував ліберальніший закон про аборти.
Він дозволив би переривати вагітність в разі аномалії ембріону, якщо,
згідно з прогнозом медиків, немовля скоріш за все буде мертвонародженим.
Час для компромісів минув. Жінки побачили, що в них відібрали
їхні права, і вони прагнуть їх повернути, вони прагнуть більших прав.
Червоні блискавки на транспарантах і масках символізують гнів жінок на чоловіків в уряді та церкві.
Цікаво, що вперше в історії поляки виходять протестувати під час богослужінь.
І не зупиняються перед вандалізмом проти церковних будівель.
На думку оглядачів, темою абортів влада намагалася відволікти увагу від прорахунків у боротьбі з коронавірусом.
Пандемію не вдалося взяти під контроль, тут налічують уже 25 тисяч нових інфікувань за добу.
Експерти кажуть, що уряд проґавив другу хвилю, і країні загрожує медична катастрофа, як навесні в Італії.
Гостро бракує місць у лікарнях, на лазарети перелаштовують стадіони.
І - гострий дефіцит медперсоналу.
ЗМІ навіть повідомляють, що Варшава на тлі коронавірусної кризи намагається переманити українських лікарів.
У Польщі чекають нових протестів.
"Жінки-страйкарки" відновлюють загальнонаціональну акцію
і закликали усіх небайдужих виходити на вулиці по понеділках, починаючи з 9 листопада.
Тепер вони прагнуть вже не пом"якшення законів про аборти, а відставки консервативного уряду.